I am Carissa Bergen a sophomore at
Hillsdale and I have a pleasure to
introduce Sir Martin Gilbert the
official biographer of Sir Winston
Churchill since 1968 and night since
1995 as this evening speaker prior to
becoming the official biographer of
Churchill he served in the British Army
for two years before entering Oxford
University in 1957 his many publications
include his eight volume biography of
Churchill his one volume Churchill a
life 12 edited volumes of Churchill
documents a series of historical atlases
a three-volume history of the 20th
century and a general history of the
Holocaust in addition to his brilliance
as an author Martin Gilbert's film and
television work includes the script for
the Academy award-winning film and
genocide the three-hour masterpiece
theater production of his book Churchill
the wilderness years and three recent
films for the History Channel on the cog
no ghetto the Israeli war for
independence and Jerusalem an
exceptional lecturer at the Ukrainian
Academy of Sciences in Kiev the Ministry
of Defense in Moscow and the State
Department in Washington DC he now joins
the lists of great men and women who had
graced Hillsdale with their presence and
imparted their wisdom unto us please
join me in welcoming Sir Martin Gilbert
well thank you very much for those
exceptionally kind words I've written on
the first page of my presentation some
words about dr. Arnn I first met Larry
if I may call him that when he was a
student and a very remarkable student
and it'd been an enormous pleasure to me
to follow his career to this college and
to the presidency of this college he and
I have often engaged in debates about
Churchill and he asked me to speak this
evening on Churchill's leadership from
1935 to 1945 this is not Churchill's
wartime leadership alone and those 10
years cover two very distinct phases in
Churchill's career during the first five
of those 10 years
Churchill was in the political
wilderness and during the second five he
was Prime Minister and yet these two
phases are linked by a single central
and animating theme the primacy of
national survival and the survival of an
open humane and free society Churchill
often described himself as a child of
the House of Commons and parliamentary
democracy essentially the ballot box and
every citizen was the focus which
animated his behavior both in opposition
in lone opposition and then at the
pinnacle of political power from 1935 to
1939
the society whose survival Churchill so
believed in whose qualities he so
believed in was under threat of
malevolent Nazi Germany without a shot
being fired democracies in Britain and
Europe were under continual threat and
during those five years Churchill while
still a member of parliament and able to
speak in the House of Commons was
totally excluded from government his
influence at the center of power his
influence in those places where
decisions were made was new to
successive British Prime Minister's
first Stanley Baldwin and then Neville
Chamberlain believed that an
accommodation with Hitler was both
possible and desirable if necessary at
the expense of small Nations Churchill
believed this to be a profound
misconception in Parliament week after
week he called on the government not to
give Hitler the impression of endless
compromise not to neglect the national
defense in all its aspects not to
exclude from its policymaking any group
in the nation not to abandon the
threatened democracies of Europe and
above all to build up a front against
potential aggression in public Churchill
did what he could he established an
anti-nazi Council to serve as a focus of
debate and of the dissemination of
knowledge and to this council he invited
members of all political parties and
from every strata of British society
from the high aristocracy those who are
not enamoured themselves of Hitler to
the trade union movement
and the working-class organizations he
also wrote in the newspapers at least
one article a week pointing out in all
its different aspects the nature of
Nazism its racism its militarism and the
need to be prepared to stand up to it
and to prepare to stand up to it
Churchill's constant speaking and
writing about the need for free peoples
to be vigilant and active in their own
defense led to a remarkable phenomenon
starting in 1934 individuals came to see
him in his home in strictest secrecy to
bring him from the inner circles of
government the truth as they had learned
it in their professional work but which
the national leaders whom they served
were unwilling to publicize every fact
that reached Baldwin and Chamberlain's
government whether from military attache
is whether from the intelligence
services whether from the Foreign Office
which the government would not allow to
influence its policy of appeasement was
brought by those who had gathered those
facts and brought them in vain to
government was brought to Winston
Churchill's door on two occasions
from Berlin first the British air
attache who had seen secret examples of
German Airy almond and then a diplomat
in the British Embassy who had heard
details of German intentions against
European countries on their return from
Germany went first to see Churchill and
then to their ministers knowing that
their ministers would dismiss what they
reported as alarmist or not in line with
British policy but knowing that
Churchill would absorb it into his
speaking and writing and above all into
his concept of what ought to be done on
one occasion the government's chief
intelligence officer for all of air raid
precautions activity for every
anti-aircraft gun for every shelter that
was being devised came to see him with
the blueprints and locations of these
guns and shelters to point out to
Churchill that not enough was being done
and that the advice of the experts was
being ignored
on one occasion Lord Mountbatten himself
came to see him in secrecy to show him
the way in which the Fleet Air Arm was
being allowed to be run down at the very
moment when it needed to be extended and
Robert watson-watt
the pioneer of radar was so disgusted by
the government scientific committee
belittling his work that he went to
Churchill urging Churchill to help him
and because in 1935 1936 1937 Churchill
by reason of his age and longevity in
politics was one of the most senior
figures in Parliament and had been the
the boss the political boss of almost
everybody who was then at the top they
had served under him in the past so of
course he was able to go to see them he
had instant access he was able to write
to them and they would read his letters
but he realized again and again whatever
the quality of the information upon
onto them he didn't fit in with their
concept of the need and possibility and
feasibility of coming to some
arrangement with Germany which would
mean that Germany would never turn its
guns and tanks and planes against
Britain in the secrecy of his cabinet
and of the cabinet committees which were
even smaller which dealt with these
matters Neville Chamberlain confided
again and again his belief that he and
Hitler could arrange between them to
make war between their two countries
impossible by agreement by mutual
admiration and to make plans between
them also essentially to control the
rest of Europe Chamberlain went so far
as to propose to Hitler an anglo-german
control of the raw materials in Africa
and the return of African territory to
Hitler now Germany's African territories
had been taken by Britain after World
War one Chamberlain didn't want to
dispose of those he was after all not
only British but also an imperialist so
he proposed to Hitler that while Britain
would retain Germany's African
territories Germany would be given as a
result of British pressure Portuguese
Africa Churchill was informed of this
plan by one of those at the very center
of the British Foreign Office who came
to see him again in secrecy probably
every week in 1937 to bring him this
information and when finally at the very
end of 1937 the about to be created
British Foreign Secretary Lord Halifax
went to see Hitler and explained to
Hitler these plans and found Hitler
receptive and was impressed by Hitler
Churchill was determined to speak out in
the House of Commons against what was
happening it's interesting to see from
the archives from Neville Chamberlain's
archives that he Chamberlain tried to
prevent this debate from taking place at
all he tried to argue with the
parliamentary managers that Lord
Halifax's visit to Hitler was somehow a
private visit that it wouldn't do to be
the subject of debate because
parliamentarians including Churchill
whom he named might criticize Hitler and
this would of course then upset the
Fuhrer who would not regard Lord Halifax
his friendly suggestions as having been
genuine but Parliament although bullied
in those years retained its independence
not very many members of parliament
joined Churchill in the criticisms of
the government but enough to make the
debates serious debates and finally on
the 12th of December 1937 the debate on
Lord Halifax his visit to Hitler took
place and Churchill went straight to the
central point how could we come to any
arrangement with a government one whole
segment whose policy was based on racial
persecution that is not a government I
say to you with which the British
democracy can do dealings it is a
horrible thing that a race of people
should be attempted to be blotted out of
the society in which they have been born
if it were thought in Europe as a result
of Lord Halifax's visit but we were
making terms for ourselves at the
expense of small nations or of large
conceptions which are there not only to
many nations but to millions of people
in every nation then a knell of despair
would resound throughout Europe
not only nations but conceptions and so
when Chamberlain prepared to transfer
Czech territory to Germany arguing that
this was legitimate that area was lived
in by german-speaking peoples though
they'd never been part of Germany and
arguing that this was Hitler's last
demand and that Hitler saying it was his
last demand could be trusted
could be believed Churchill again argued
it is not a question of transfer of
territory it is a question of morality
it's the question of how human beings
are to relate to each other I begged the
House of Commons not to ignore the moral
forces involved in public policy for
five years I've been asking the House on
the government to make our armaments
guns aeroplanes munitions but I am quite
sure that British armaments alone will
never protect us in the times through
which we will have to pass it was a
belief in the centrality of moral forces
and the fear that Britain was losing out
was abandoning its moral principles that
were central to Churchill's arguments in
opposition and was central to his
leadership in wartime
war came for Britain with Hitler's
invasion of Poland in September 1939 two
days after that invasion Britain
declared war on Germany Churchill was
brought into the government in charge of
the Navy a post he had held at the
outbreak of World War one and then in
May 1940 he became Prime Minister prime
minister of an all-party government a
truly national government of the sort
that Neville Chamberlain had refused to
set up even after the outbreak of war
the first factor in Churchill's war
leadership his first achievement
was to give full ministerial and cabinet
posts and position of authority
throughout the war making instrument to
those who had been his strongest
adversaries and critics in the past as
well as to his former supporters to give
these positions to right and left to
labour and conservative to trade
unionists and political mavericks anyone
whom he believed could help drive
forward
the war effort so lacking was he in
vindictiveness but Neville Chamberlain
the man who had kept him out of office
in the very years that he believed he
could have done something to avert war
that Neville Chamberlain remained at
Churchill's suggestion at 10 Downing
Street because he was a sick man dying
of cancer and Churchill did not want him
to have the terrible difficult isn't
inconvenience of moving house at such a
time and so this man who had so wanted
to be Prime Minister for such a long
time spent his first weeks as Prime
Minister not in the famous 10 Downing
Street but remaining in admiralty house
his naval headquarters among the members
of parliament in his constituency was a
young man who had tried to remove him
with Neville Chamberlain's encouragement
from his seat in Parliament this young
man wrote to Churchill on the 10th of
May 1940 apologizing groveling profusely
for having less than a year earlier
tried to eject him from the House of
Commons and Churchill replied thanking
from from his letter and for its
sentiments and saying but I have to tell
you as for me the past is dead
during the first weeks of Churchill's
Premiership many of those who had
opposed the appeasement policy of
Chamberlain were angry that Churchill
was not throwing out and wreaking some
sort of vengeance on those who in the
immediate pre-war years had opposed
rearmament had wanted to go in with
Hitler had wanted to betray Jackson
Avakian and in what is arguably his most
important speech of the war his speech
of the 18th of June 1940 the blood toil
tears and sweat speech he broke off from
his description of the battle and of the
tremendous dangers then threatening
Britain with the collapse of France to
say as follows there are many who had
hold an inquest in the House of Commons
on the conduct of past governments and
Parliament's this would be a foolish and
pernicious process of this I am quite
sure that if we open a quarrel between
the past and the present we shall find
that we have lost the future and so he
insisted on absolute loyalty within his
government towards those who a few
months earlier had been his strongest
critics and indeed he appointed a sector
of State for war the very Chief Whip
David Morrison who had been the one who
had constantly organized Parliament and
fudged things up in Parliament so that
Churchill would speak less would have
less opportunities to speak so the
debates would be curtailed because he
knew that this marginal a First World
War soldier of considerable bravery
would make a first-class Secretary of
State for war a second factor in
Churchill's leadership
and this had been seen in the years in
the wilderness was his ability to speak
to ordinary people
he had no edge to his voice although he
came from very aristocratic family he
had no aristocratic airs his great
delight if he found himself in a street
with a group of people it might be a
street that had been badly bombed or a
street in which soldiers were preparing
were parading or firefighters were
getting ready for thee for the evenings
blitz and burning his great delight was
to somehow bounce forward from his aides
from his assistance from his guard
bounce forward almost like a schoolboy
into the midst of the melee and he was a
little person and he would disappear
surrounded by whoever the people were he
wanted to talk to and they somehow
recognized his great quality in this
regard someone once asked him why is it
called the century of the common man
that was a phrase people used about the
20th century and he replied it is called
the century of the common man because in
it the common man has suffered most and
somehow the man and woman in the street
in Britain recognized that he knew of
their plight and when in 1945 they voted
for labour to come to power and
throughout the Conservatives and with
them Churchill and all sorts of people
said to him goodness me how could the
British public have been found grateful
he replied you haven't seen what they
had to live through before the war why
should they put up with a repetition of
the pre-war failures essentially of
conservative governments of course they
will throw out any Conservative
government and try to set a new course
the third feature in Churchill's
leadership was something very difficult
to reconstruct because we know that the
war was won by us by the Allies and that
Hitler and Nazism were destroyed and
that unconditional surrender probably
the most important single decision of
Churchill and Roosevelt together was
achieved but in May in June 1940 it was
not the defeat of Germany that people
were pondering it was whether Britain
could herself survive survive through
the summer and autumn survive into the
winter and when Churchill spoke and
here's another curious fact history is
so complicated very interesting such a
tapestry Churchill had not wanted to
broadcast he made his speech in the
House of Commons and he didn't feel that
he could really convey to the public but
although things were terrible there was
a way forward and it was Neville
Chamberlain who Churchill had kept in
his government who said to him after one
cabinet you know Winston if you could
only broadcast what you've said to us
this afternoon to the people it would
make an enormous difference and so
Churchill at Chamberlain's suggestion
went to Broadcasting House if you listen
to the original recording you can hear
the bombardment he went into the cellar
to the sort of shelter broadcasting room
and there he broadcast and what he said
I think holds the key to the success of
his leadership and you'll hear it he he
spoke at some length about the the
dangers about the bombardment
but then he turned to an extraordinary
topic you ask what is our aim
I can answer in one word victory victory
at all costs victory in spite of all
terror victory however long and hard the
road might be for without victory there
is no survival let that be realized no
survival for the urge and impulse of all
the ages that mankind will move forward
towards its goal well to talk in the
midst of the blitz of victory and to
link that victory with mankind's onward
progress was something which caught
people's imagination it was something
extraordinary about it if this man who
surely knew all the the facts of the
situation as he did all the bad facts
could still use the word victory make
victory his aim then there had to be
some point not just in holding on but in
working hard and harder towards that
victory
these aspects of Churchill's leadership
were built up on many facets his
character and his experience and that
experience went back in nineteen forty
forty years he had experienced warfare
at the end of the 19th and beginning of
the 20th century and during World War
one in the trenches on the Western Front
and he had no illusions about what war
meant indeed when I was listening at
lunchtime to that most powerful and
moving account of the Pacific War I was
reminded of something Churchill wrote to
his wife about war telling her I quote
what vile and utter folly and barbarism
war is so he was not without knowledge
of that aspect of war the horrendous
aspect but as he explained to the House
of Commons after Neville Chamberlain had
expressed his delight at ceding Czech
territory to Hitler and had said we have
averted war Churchill said not only do I
not believe you've averted war you've
merely thrown one more morsel to the
crocodile but he said war is terrible
but slavery is worse the British people
did not want to be slaves dictatorship
and totalitarianism was as alien to them
as foreign rule and they had confidence
that he shared this view because he had
expressed it all his life he had labored
day and night during the First World War
or in several Central War directing
tasks including between nineteen
seventeen and eighteen and this is a
subject on which your president is the
expert laboring as minister of munitions
the crucial ministry that would enable
the war to be won and not as we learnt
this afternoon not one easily as some
sort of game but possibly not one until
after that great offensive of the first
of July 1919 had pitted the armies
together for yet another year his
experiences between the wars had also
brought him very close to an
understanding of how easy it was for
democracy to be overwhelmed whether in
Russia by communism whether in Germany
during the first war revolutions in 1919
and then in 1933 with Hitler's coming to
power or indeed all over Europe and
elsewhere he had watched with horror the
Japanese invasion and pillage and
destruction in China and the Italian
destruction using poison gas in Ethiopia
in looking at Church of leadership I've
often been surprised while working
through the archives at how often this
man who can be portrayed has been
portrayed as some sort of grumpy moody
grim looking frowning almost tyrannical
and of course drunk depressed how this
is William Manchester describes him sort
of grotesque figure really how in fact
he was a source of light and
enlightenment and encouragement to all
those around him generals would come to
see him wondering whether they were
going to get a flee in the air and would
find that he had not only studied very
carefully what had been done by that
general but approved it and encouraged
it and urged him to go on on one
occasion a very nervous British diplomat
who was working in Belgrade at the time
when Britain was fomenting a pro allied
revolution among the pro-german
administration there in April 1941 and
this rather nervous diplomat who done
wonderful work to try to change the
focus of the Yugoslav government had
sent Churchill a telegram describing
what he'd done and nervously asking what
the Prime Minister thought he ought to
do and he got a reply all you are doing
is excellent continue to pester nag and
bite which the diplomat certainly did
he had to take very difficult decisions
and just as he could be a source and was
a constant source of encouragement to
all those working under him so when
something very difficult emerged it was
brought to his desk he was the Prime
Minister and probably the single most
difficult decision he ever had to make
was one which was mentioned by Professor
Weinberg this afternoon in answered one
of the questions and that was the
decision after the French Admiral at
Iran had refused to hand over his
section of the French fleet either to
the British or to sail it to a neutral
port or to sail it to the Caribbean he
had to make the decision because Britain
was on the verge of being invaded by
Germany and the Germans needed these
French warships as part of their
invasion fleet the decision to bombard
while it was a tanker these French
vessels on more than 1,500 French
sailors who had been our allies only a
few weeks before were killed now the
interesting thing is all Admiralty
orders go out signed by the First Sea
Lord who was a very remarkable sailor
called Admiral pound and it was for
pound to actually send the order for the
destruction of the French fleet and
Churchill summoned pound to his room and
he said is the order ready to go out and
pound said yes and Churchill said let me
sign it why should you be the one to be
condemned by history he didn't want this
professional sailor to somehow be
tarnished by something which he knew in
subsequent decades and ages would be a
matter
of deep historical conscious II he took
the responsibility just as he had taken
the decision and curiously many years
later 30 years later I was doing
research in the Chateau where Churchill
as minister of munitions in 1917-18 had
lived while in France and the owner of
the chateau had been the same man in
1917 as he was when I turned up at his
door a very elderly man and his son met
me at the door and he said my father
says you're welcome to look round the
house to look at any of our archives but
he's afraid he can't meet you he can't
shake your hand because he hasn't shaken
the hand of any Englishman
since Churchill destroyed the French
fleet at Oran and so of course I
respected his decision his decision to
bombard the French fleet was one which
he later wrote was the only decision
during the war which made him physically
sick the only other time he was
physically sick according to the
historical record was when he gave the
order for the continuation after a gap
of the convoys to Russia taking vital
British and American military aid to
Russia these convoys which were
suffering such horrendous loss as they
made their way around the North Cape of
Norway and he had to make the decision
that they would continue but Russia had
to be kept in the war that Britain in
the United States were pledged to do
this and would maintain their pledge was
another difficult set of decisions he
had to make and that was replacing
commanders replacing commanders in chief
and I don't think he angry over anything
as much
as he anguished over the need to remove
a commander-in-chief someone whose name
of course was very much in the public
eye general waiver general Auchinleck
these commanders of vast armies when he
Churchill received reports from their
staff from people in the field even
sometimes from them of their extreme
tiredness of their inability to carry on
with their job of their feeling of not
being up to it anymore it was one thing
to learn this it was another thing to
say then you have to go and take of
course the brunt of public or probiem
for having sacked a commander he did it
and in the end not unlike Roosevelt who
was fortunate was more fortunate at the
beginning in the end by certainly early
1942
Churchill had the commanders in chief
who he regarded as the ones who would be
able to do the job though even there if
one fell below the level of events was
unable to carry the burden he too had to
go and then there was the occasion which
was alluded to earlier today when he
appointed general got to succeed general
Auchinleck general got was killed in an
air crash as he flew to take up his
appointment and so he cast around for
someone else and general Montgomery was
the one chosen and Churchill's wife
wrote to him not just the historians of
later years Churchill's wife wrote to
him and said are you sure you're doing
the right thing I hear from everybody
who knows him that general Montgomery is
extremely disagreeable
and Churchill replied I have not only
heard but I know the general Montgomery
is extremely disagreeable to all those
around him I can assure you my dearest
he will be even more disagreeable to the
enemy and so it and so it proved
no biographer perhaps finds it easy I
won't say likes it because it can be a
likeable process but no bog refer finds
it easy to piece together the support
system whereby the person he's writing
about was kept going was kept alive has
kept alert was kept supplied was kept
informed and I've no doubt the church
was extremely lucky in two elements
around him without which perhaps his
life his leadership could not have been
as effective as they were first of all
what we in Britain call the private
office or the private secretary had
those five young men I think the oldest
was certainly not 40 and most were in
their late twenties and early thirties
who were with him day and night in
relays who brought him
hour after hour boxes buff colored boxes
filled with the things that needed
decisions the letters the problems were
requests the ones that had to feed as it
were the machine had to know what to put
in front of him how much to put in front
of him what things to bring back what
things were urgent a document which had
on it top of the box
meant that one of this private office
had realized these were men who had to
be very well attuned to what was
happening realize this issue this
document had to be dealt with by the
prime minister immediately because in
this box there might be and I've worked
with one British Prime Minister thirty
or forty documents each of which needed
the Prime Minister's decision and during
the course of an evening even in
peacetime five or six boxes would be
brought up as one was cleared another
one brought up
Churchill remembered so many things
about World War one and he remembered in
particular something which we historians
probably neglect which is the role of
horses and particularly the artillery
horses the gun horses so many hundreds
of thousands millions of whom perished
in war and on one occasion one of his
private office brought him up the eighth
or ninth box of that evening it must be
nearly midnight and the lad was wilting
and he said to the Prime Minister Prime
Minister I don't know how I can go on I
don't know how you can go on and
Churchill looked at him with his
beatific smile and said my dear we must
all go on like the gun horses till we
drop and there's no doubt that had he
reached the stage of dropping he would
have done it and so these young men of
the private office made sure that he was
undisturbed that he got his rest but he
got the information he needed the
telephone calls that had to be made were
put through at the right time and that
the whole apparatus of hourly work was
maintained and in his desk Diaries one
sees that it wasn't only hourly work but
normally he would have Churchill would
have 15 to 20 minutes
to deal with some vital question for
which two or three people perhaps had
come to see him some generals and
admirals some air marshals some
munitions expert the the pressure the
amount of work involved was such the 20
minutes might be all but these people
and the Prime Minister had and so side
by side with the private office
Churchill developed an incredible system
of delegation of work he believed that
every instruction compressor
Weinberger's mentioned these archives of
his correspondence his minutes to
everybody in his circle Churchill
believed that everything should be in
writing but that once something was
agreed it should be preceded with once
it was agreed and it was decided that if
someone put up to him a document asking
for something and he put his tick in the
margin the tick would be sufficient for
his authority they didn't require his
signature a date a whole apparatus of
descriptive material if he felt this is
something that can be proceeded with
then a tick was all that was needed
because who were days when a tick was
almost all he had time for and so he
created a system of Committees of
experts and once he had given the
general instruction of what needed to be
done those committees worked
uninterrupted he wasn't an interferer in
their work each committee submitted
their reports to him and again one often
just sees his tick or well down or yes
or so proceeded these little comments in
the margin sometimes of course something
riled him he thought something was wrong
and then there could be almost an essay
but in the main I'd say 90 times out of
100 or 95 times out of 100 it was this
delegated responsibility but it made it
possible to do everything and at the
center of the delegation were the Chiefs
of
and you're president and I have often
discussed and indeed we again discussed
this evening this extraordinary
phenomenon that the Chiefs of Staff
Committee of which church was a member
the three Chiefs of Staff the chief of
the secret intelligence services and the
prime minister meeting often twice a day
and having to decide both morning and
evening on many important issues often
two or three major issues relating to
the conduct of the war the dispatch of
troops the bombing offensive the
relationship of the United States the
military procedures which operations to
go ahead with which operations to
postpone which operations to review in
this grouping no one had a dictatorial
say if Churchill wanted something
however strongly and three of the five
were opposed to it it did not go ahead
he would argue he had a good line in
argument he knew had to put a case he
knew had to put his view forward he
wasn't shy or timid he could even bang
the desk but if the Chiefs of Staff
Committee opposed it he did not go ahead
similarly if he opposed something which
the majority wanted his opposition was
overruled and what I discovered in going
through I do know perhaps a thousand of
these decisions was that it almost never
was the Prime Minister against the
others or even the Prime Minister plus
one against the others these were all
people who essentially were trying to
get the right answer
trying to send the troops of the ships
or the planes in the right direction and
therefore it wasn't a sort of struggle a
contest in who was clever or who spoke
louder it was a desperate attempt to
work out the best thing
and so there was no need for Churchill
to be a dictator even had he had the
means in this committee which he did not
to be won
I suppose finally his greatest quality
of leadership in world war ii which is
again mischaracterized by some of his
biographers with the incredible word
interference imagine if he'd laid on his
couch or his divan in the afternoon and
not bothered to poke his finger into
anything what would we say of him as a
war leader then I don't he ever
interfered but he watched like a hawk
every single aspect of the war I'll give
you an example
he is we've heard on us both frezzle
Weinberg and I have written at length he
put in Norma's stall on the good
relationship with the United States and
with Roosevelt because he understood
from the first day that without American
participation support help and eventual
direct involvement that could be no
victory but he understood that there was
a terrible and still is element of
anti-americanism tolerating right
through British society particularly
through British official circles so
every he insisted on seeing every
telegram from every British mission in
Washington of which there were certainly
fifty and the may have been seventy-two
find anything he thought was a
belittling of the United States they
talking down to the Americans and he
would be on to it like a hawk and a one
occasion the great Admiral danckwerts
who thought he knew far better than the
United States how the sea war should be
conducted was recalled overnight from
the United States and Church elicited
general instruction I will not allow
this sort of expression of
anti-americanism by those charged with
bringing the United States and us along
together so he watched everything every
morning one of this private office one
of these young men brought him a a chart
about that size on a board and on this
chart is a simple factual chart was
marked every single ship that was in an
American port loading and what it was
loading every ship that was crossing the
Atlantic from the United States to
Britain what was in it what speed it was
going was it part of a convoy what was
the convoy what was the convoy escort at
what point does a lass often happened
would it lose its escort at the time
when we couldn't do complete convoys and
then every ship in British ports
unloading what was it unloading how long
had it been unloading when would it set
sail again because these ports were
under almost continual bombardment by
Germany and he could spot he he had a he
was lucky to have a photographic memory
and you would often say but wait a
minute four days ago wasn't this ship
already docking in Liverpool why hasn't
it unloaded let what's gone wrong and I
found an amazing example in my own life
I was one of those people who were
evacuated to the New World in the summer
of 1940 and in May 1944 before d-day
Churchill discovered by looking at his
charts that the Mauretania was about to
leave New York with less than 2,000
troops on board because all the American
troops had long ago arrived in you're in
Britain for d-day and so he just wrote a
little note in red why don't we bring
back 4,000 of the children who were sent
over to a new world and then he added
and make sure there are sufficient
lifebelts aboard the ship for this extra
card so had we gone down even his
vigilance on the line
belts would have been effective well in
the House of Commons inevitably because
it also continued for so many members of
parliament who had not liked him
they was an initial phalanx some of whom
I met when I began my researches who
were still members of parliament in the
1940s who hated him for having created
the Irish Free State in 1921 how dare he
give southern ireland its independence
strange it's such an antique story there
are last two with us in Britain but that
was one of the indictments against him
there were many more he's attitude to
India and the night early 1930s and on
one occasion and I'll end with this
rather marvelous parliamentary moment a
prime minister in the midst of war
suddenly criticised by a member of
parliament for not being active enough
and this member of parliament suggested
that what was required was a group of
people who would constantly be badgering
Churchill to get on with this to get on
with that to get on with the other and
he got up in his place in the House of
Commons and looked around over his
glasses of his reading glasses which he
kept on and he said I certainly do not
think I am one of those who needs to be
prodded in fact if anything I am a prod
thank you
we have time for just a few questions
somebody in charge of the mic so Marcin
during your talk you've talked a great
deal about Sir Winston Churchill I
wonder if you'd comment on the great
speeches he made during World War two
and how they helped to unify the British
people and all of Whiston Western
civilization
mogera against the great onslaught of
Nazi tyranny would you comment on those
speeches please I've been asked to
comment on Churchill's wartime speeches
I thought I'd said something about them
of course was much more than could be
said about them first of all it was
always a tremendous effort for him to
prepare a speech speech making didn't
come naturally to him any more than
lecturing comes naturally to most of
those you will hear lecture together for
a substantial parliamentary speech he
would often have to take off three or
four days three or four full days from
the business of war he found it very
difficult although we are familiar with
his parish ins the majority of his
parliamentary speeches and most of the
speeches he gave were parliamentary
speeches were long they could run to two
hours and very detailed he was the
master of expounding a complicated case
in considerable detail and indeed he had
a technique when there was criticism and
it's not a stupid technique of leading
his critics through stage by stage and
paced by tape very slowly
point by point in fact by fact through
the case addition so you sat if you're
in the House of Commons through speeches
which you had to listen to they were
carefully crafted but they were
and they were detailed speakers and the
the great preparations were in a sense
the cream or the icing on the cake as I
say he didn't find it easy didn't relish
making these speeches I mentioned that
Neville Chamberlain was the one who as
it were propelled him forward to his
first broadcast but what he did realize
and this was brought to him of course by
people who came out of nazi-occupied
Europe and out of Germany was that these
speeches were being listened to
clandestinely and a great danger by
people who weren't allowed to have
radios let alone listen to foreign
brokers were being listened to and was
serving as a source of inspiration to
captive people's he was very conscious
of that now unlike many recently
contemporary statesmen he wrote his own
speeches he either wrote them out in
longhand or he dictated and then
polished his own thoughts I found three
speeches each of considerate importance
where he brought in material from the
foreign office from the War Office and
so we had to deal with extremely
technical matters but he wrote his own
speeches and he had an ability I suppose
this is partly the answer to your
question he had an ability to read his
speeches which were broadcast ones in
very pokey studios with no audience just
two or three of his staff sitting on the
side as if he somehow could picture the
whole British people in front of him and
he had had by 1940 forty five years
experience for dressing audiences in the
flesh this was long
before the television age he had gone
from city to city since 1894 1895
talking to people he knew how to
communicate now tell you one lovely
story about quality of his mind when he
made sketches after the fall of France
in 1940 he was asked by a number of
distinguished Frenchmen in exile among
them to go and Maurice Schumann and Jean
Monet later really the creator of the
united europe he was asked to broadcast
to the French people and he prepared in
English and in French a short speech
beautiful little speech which basically
says bad times of calm but eventually
things will be all right and he was a he
was a great student of France and French
history he was actually of a very he
knew a great deal about the past of his
country in all countries and in the
course of this speech he wanted to refer
to a remark Napoleon had made at the
Battle of Waterloo which would give the
French a tremendous booths because
Napoleon had said these same Prussians
who are yapping around us now who
outnumber us so much
once we defeated them when they
outnumbered us even more so that would
be an ISTAT all shot in the arms of the
French and he came to read it and I've
seen his actual reading text and as he
came said as Napoleon said before and it
said the Battle of Waterloo and he
suddenly realized as he was reading it
to the microphone you can't talk to the
French in June 1940 about the Battle of
Waterloo which they lost so he suddenly
said as Napoleon said before one of his
battles
um I was just wondering um when later
when Stalin decided to become in the
circle between the United States and
Great Britain
how did Churchill feel about that oh
when Stalin later decided to become in
the circle between the United States and
Great Britain how did Churchill feel
about that well this is a very good
questions a difficult question away
how did Churchill feel when Stalin came
as it were between him and United States
when Stalin joined the big three and of
course was no doubt the Churchill knew
from the start that ultimately it was a
big - and that he was lucky to be there
it always amused him women the goal then
insisted on being part of it the big
form is ever we're not really part of
this team
Churchill had a a date in his in his
knowledge of history which was a year
six or seven years before the outbreak
of World War one the date he would often
produce when talking after dinner to
people particularly people who were
anti-american or wanted to pit somehow
the British Empire against the American
Republic and he would produced this date
it was the year in which the industrial
production of the United States exceeded
that of Britain France and Germany and
combined and he liked to produce that
figure if they don't since that date
everything we do one way or another is
within the shadow of the United States
course will preserve our independence
we'll fight our end we'll fight our wars
but don't forget he was minister of
munitions when the United States entered
the war decisively in 1917 and he knew
exactly what that meant for the outcome
of the war that it would be the turning
point so in that sense the relationship
with the United States for him was not
difficult though it involved a lot of
difficult activities on one occasion one
of his staff was a little uneasy at a
message he'd sent to Roosevelt which the
member of staff thought was perhaps a
little too groveling a little too to
deferring to Brazil to you and Churchill
looked at him with a sweet smile and
said but don't you understand since the
beginning I have wound President
Roosevelt like a man might whooaaa made
and he understood that animal the
Russian dimension was much harder for
him first of all at the time of the
Bolshevik Revolution in 1917 he had been
one of the leading figures to insist
upon an allied attempt to destroy vos
schism indeed the United States had
initially played its part in that
attempt together with many other
countries Woodrow Wilson's very last day
of the Paris Peace Conference was spent
discussing with Churchill the future of
the Allied intervention against the
Baltics but when Hitler invaded the
Soviet Union in June 1941 Churchill
understood from many different
perspectives that the Soviet Union had
to be supported
he understood partly from his knowledge
of German intentions his knowledge
derived from secret sources that the
defeat of the Soviet Union which was
considered and debated would it be in
August or September October 1941 those
who said the Soviet Union wouldn't be
defeated in October 41 was thought to be
bizarre optimists and he understood that
the moment the Soviet Union was defeated
then a tremendous German Armada
reinforced by all sorts of things would
turn against Britain and this was in
June 1941 and so he made the commitment
he made it within three or four hours he
broadcasted on the night following the
German invasion of the Soviet Union
having consulted with colleagues that
Britain would give every support it
could to the Soviet Union and then
he found that he could take Roosevelt
with him and so an extraordinary
phenomenon developed for example the
whole of several months tank and
aircraft production built here in the
United States for Britain and
desperately needed for Britain's war
effort on arriving of British ports
would be unloaded often with the fitters
still on board the ship's still
completing the items the ship would
leave the dock another ship would come
here these items tanks guns aircraft
would be loaded on the other ship a ship
which have been specially designed for
Arctic waters and taken round to the
Soviet Arctic ports this was an
incredible thing an incredible risk but
it was done to prevent the defeat of the
Soviet Union and it was a successful
maneuver it included providing Stalin
not on a daily but on an hourly basis
with information derived from German
radio signals as to what the German
commanders-in-chief
air and army commanders-in-chief were
being instructed to do later that day in
the field against the Soviet forces and
again and again I've come across
examples where the German
commander-in-chief wasn't at his command
car he'd gone to the front with his men
meanwhile the same signal that was
waiting for him when he came back three
hours later to his command car telling
him to attack north-northwest at 5:23
a.m. had been decrypted in Britain sent
with Churchill's and systems to Moscow
sent by Moscow to the Soviet
commander-in-chief facing the German
again and again knew what the
instructions were to his German
adversary before the German had received
them and took of course appropriate
action
so by this tremendous
effort of which the intelligence was
central we sustained the Soviet Union
and we provided as you know through our
joint missions from Beaverbrook and
Harriman massive supplies of armaments
medical supplies and so on then of
course came the day when the tide of war
was reversed after another year and a
half's fierce fighting gradually the
Russian armies began to move against the
Germans taking off the battle of course
in 1943 and then another situation
developed and then the problems which
you refer to became all too clear Stalin
was not going to say thank you by
relinquishing his political ambitions
and intentions and so the moment he
reached a certain point in the old
Polish border he announced that Poland
have to move westward the Russia would
take over those areas not only that it
was established in Poland a communist
government and at that point Churchill
Roosevelt in different ways and often
very closely together and sometimes with
disagreements for to somehow work out a
way of restraining this giant there was
a day which you could work out when you
look at your chronology of World War 2
there was a day on which no Soviet
soldier stood in Belgrade Buda pest
Sofia Bucharest Warsaw or Prague what
Irama and on that day
Churchill pleaded with Stalin to come to
a conference with him and Roosevelt so
they could somehow establish the
principles of the Atlantic Charter
one-man one-vote free elections in those
countries which it was clear the Soviet
forces would within months
certainly within a year being control of
Stalin declined to go to the conference
Churchill and Roosevelt worked hard to
try to create what became subsequently
the Yalta Conference by which time all
these capital cities and countries I'd
mentioned were under Soviet control and
at that point basically Churchill
realize that the Atlantic Charter
principles indeed the altar declaration
promising free elections in Poland that
these things were simply sheets of paper
depending on Stalin's goodwill and that
Stalin's goodwill did not exist and in
Churchill's very first letter to Truman
after the deaths of Roosevelt this is
the theme of the letter what do we do
confronted by this situation and as he
put it in his letter to Truman an iron
curtain is drawn down on the front the
phrase he was later to use two years
later at Fulton Missouri or a year later
at Fulton Missouri so that was really
the as he saw his Churchill sword in
retrospect the not the failure of the
war because he was a great believer that
you had to defeat Germany you couldn't
start playing games while Germany was
still undefeated with regard to the
post-war world because there would be no
post-war world unless Germany was
defeated and the Soviet Union as he and
Roosevelt both appreciated and as
Churchill certainly referred to a great
deal and also in their correspondence
was putting by far the largest number of
men in the field at any given time and
for long periods of the war were the
only soldiers effectively fighting on
any substantial war front so that was a
failure but I think you just have to say
that the defeat of Hitler was was the
success that mattered at that time